what how who's house are you in uh i'm
in a rental house at oklahoma in
oklahoma city
because you're filming what are you
filming
well i was filming a movie called the
unbreakable boy and we finished that and
then i
went home for the holidays for a couple
of weeks and uh then i'm coming back and
basically with like 50
of the same crew we're about to shoot
this movie american underdog which is
the kurt warner
um football quarterback biola right
you're kurt warner
yeah yeah have you been practicing oh
yeah
can you throw a football can you throw a
football i could do a football pretty
well i mean i don't know that i throw it
as good as kurt warner but you know
i mean geez louise
you know when you throw that good you
play in the nfl that's true but uh
yeah no i've been i've been doing a lot
of like um
uh strength and conditioning uh training
uh
all through like once i got to oklahoma
i started uh training and all through
shooting the last film i was doing that
and
and also um some qb training even before
i came to oklahoma i had a qb coach
who's now here in oklahoma with me and
we're going to be running drills and
you know just getting just getting
formed down and making sure
not even just how to throw a football
well
uh or you know um what it means to be a
quarterback but specifically
to emulate curt as best i can and so you
know
he my quarterback coach is kind of
breaking down the various things that
you know kurt would do is the way he
steps back in the pocket the way he kind
of
bounces the way whatever it is how you
move with the ball
how your head's moving do you move your
head at all and unfortunately i was even
able to
um in this little holiday break i was
able to i road tripped uh
uh me and my girlfriend road trip from
uh la to phoenix and i was able to go
hang out with kurt warner and his family
uh for a couple of days and just absorb
them and their dynamic and their you
hung out with kurt warner for a few days
like at his house
yeah yeah isn't that bizarre is that
like john byner remember john byner
it was super bizarre i've never really
done
i i you know like the unbreakable boy
that i did prior to this
is a is kind of a biopic
in that it's about a real family and i
was representing and i was
playing the husband and father in this
real family
but um he and i very looked very
different
in real life and you know the the the
movie has a lot of it takes a lot of
not a lot of but i mean it takes enough
of our artistic liberty to kind of you
know
create it and weave it all together in
the way that those things typically do
and no one's gonna be i don't you know
the public scrutiny isn't looking at me
and this other gentleman scott loretta
his name is right nobody's being like
wait a minute but
everybody knows kurt warner so there's a
whole another level of scrutiny that
you're under
when you're when you're representing
being someone that is so well known and
famous i think
well look as as a as someone who you
know i know sports i i play football i
could actually throw the ball i'm not
you know i'm not bullshitting i could
throw you know
i have videos of me throwing a ball i
could throw a freaking football i mean i
believe i can i'm telling you obviously
nobody's
you know kurt warner level i mean you
know tom brady but like kurt warner
what is interesting about if i don't
know anything about football why would i
go see a kurt warner what what is the
catch
what is the same question yeah i mean
what's it what's it interesting what's
the story like in an in a nutshell don't
break it down but just in a nutshell
the movie's not really about the
football the football is
the packaging in that like it's it's an
incredible rags to riches cinderella
story and the nfl is one of the most
insane places that ever
trying to make that thing happen but
it's 25
football 75 the real life
journey of kurt and brenda and their and
their kids
their kids and it's beautiful
it's got so much heart and so much faith
and um
it just is it's a very uh it's a very
uh uplifting yeah uplifting humbling
uh uh encouraging story
we need that i think we need more of
that all oh my god i need more of it i
need more of it
you know